(audience cheering)
(mellow music)
- Hello!
- Hello.
Look at us in New York.
- [Kelly] Look at you, yep,
this is a good color on you!
- This is for you.
- I love it.
Well, happy belated birthday.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you,
appreciate it.
- You're 42, right?
- I'm 42.
- We're the same age.
I turned 42 this year.
- So I heard.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's great over here.
- I love 40's.
- 40's Is amazing.
- Yes!
- Yeah.
- You know what the 40's are, an exhale.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience and Dwyane laughing)
It's an exhale.
- Yeah, you can breathe.
- Yeah, you're just like,
"You know what (exhales)?"
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm better in my 40's.
- Did you have a good party?
- I had a very nice party back in Miami,
with friends and family on the beach,
'cause I love the water.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And so, I wanted to
have the water next to me
and a nice little tented dinner.
- Yeah!
- Some music and vibe, easy.
- Dinner on the beach?
- Yeah.
- Sexy birthday!
- [Dwyane] Kinda.
(audience chucking)
- Yeah, I like it.
All right, well, Dwyane had a
special serenade at his party.
This is a weird segue, but whatever.
We have a clip of it.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear Daddy ♪
(guests cheering)
- Aww!
(audience applauding)
It makes you wanna have more children.
It's like they're so cute like that.
That was a surprise, right?
- I had no idea.
I didn't know she can hit
that daddy note, I didn't,
like that was a note right there.
- And when she says
"Daddy," it crushes you
and puts you back together, it's, yeah.
- She does it.
I mean, obviously when I
look at her, I see my face,
and my body, you know, all the things,
but just, you know, her love
for me is just, is unmatched, so.
- Oh, it's so cool.
- She's beautiful, beautiful soul.
She has a beautiful soul,
yeah, I love her soul.
- And there's something so innocent
and pure when children sing,
they're not thinking
about anything else other
than that it feels good.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Dwyane] I didn't know she could sing.
- They're not jaded by anything yet, yeah.
- I had no idea.
You know, we play around,
but I didn't know she's
gonna grab the microphone
and just tell everybody
be quiet and do her thing.
- Yeah.
(audience chuckling)
She's like, "My moment."
- Yeah, she waited like, "Y'all good?
Okay."
- Yeah.
"I will wait till I'm respected."
(Kelly chuckling)
- It's like a teacher.
- That's Kaavia, everybody.
- So wait, you were just in Miami,
but you were also recently
honored in Miami, right?
- I was.
- Yeah.
- How was that?
- I was honored with a statue.
- [Kelly] I know, so that's crazy.
- Yes, thank you.
(audience cheering)
- It's a bronze statue of you.
(audience applauding)
Did you have any input on
this statue, by the way?
- I do, I do.
- Oh, okay.
- I knew before the audience knew.
I had to sit down with the Heat.
But it was great to share it
in Miami with the audience,
with the fan base that's been there.
That statue is all of our statue.
We all are invested into Miami
Heat, putting that statue up.
And so, the fact that it's
gonna happen later this year,
it's gonna be pretty cool, so.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, of course I'm excited
and all the things, but it's
kind of weird too like who-
- [Kelly] There's a statue of you.
- What's a statue?
- I don't know, it's...
Not many people have one.
- Right, I knew monuments,
I don't know like,
you know like, it's not...
I'm alive and so...
- I'm alive.
(everyone laughing)
- You know what I mean?
- I am not dead yet.
- No, normally when you think of it,
you think of monuments.
- I'm alive, so.
- And I'm 42, and I'm like,
"Wow, I'm getting a statue?"
I feel like I should be older in my life.
- I feel like every time you go
to Miami though, you have
to take a picture with it.
- I will.
- 'Cause you are alive, so.
- Well, I told them,
I was asking 'em
like, "What are you guys
gonna do at nighttime
when people wanna come and
enjoy themselves by my statue?"
- [Kelly] Yeah, light it up.
- Yeah, and they was like,
"Well, we may have security, may not."
I was like, "Well, I'm
talking about myself.
I may come at like 2:00 in the morning
and like, bring my music."
- And be like, "Damn!
I got a statue!"
- Yeah, bring my music and
you know, do my TikToks
in front of my own statue.
I don't know.
- Exactly,
or your podcast.
- Or my podcast right out there.
- "Here's The Why, I got a
statue," yeah (chuckles).
- Welcome to The Why.
- Yeah, welcome to The Why.
- Right behind me.
- I got a statue, I want a statue.
(audience cheering)
So we were talking about
in the break a little
bit, I wanna first get
to your podcast.
I love The Why, that's what it's called.
How did you come up with the name?
- Because it's something
I've been dealing with my entire life.
My name has been misspelled-
- By me.
- No matter where I go,
no matter where I go in life, all the way
to the Hall of Fame, they
will still misspell my name.
It is always, people always put D-W-A-Y,
mine is D-W-Y-A.
And so, I'm taking my Y back.
- Okay.
- Right, in my name.
And so, if you see my podcast-
- It's after the W, people.
- You see my logo,
it's after the W, it's D-W-Y.
And so, you see the logo,
the Y is what's highlighted.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And also too, the why, your why
in life continues to evolve,
it continues to change.
And so, it's something
that I felt was great to be able
to talk to with guests, like
right now as you sit here-
- It's a brilliant conversation topic!
Just for even if you're at a dinner.
- And you need that.
- Yeah like, "Oh, why
did you want to do this?"
Or, "Why are you in this relationship?"
Or, "Why," like all the things.
- It can go so many different ways.
- Yeah!
- So, The Why
with Dwyane Wade.
- Are your conversations, do they go
in just such different directions
depending on who you have on, obviously?
- Yeah like asking Pat Riley his why
at roughly 80 years old
and asking Carmelo
Anthony, who just retired
from the game of basketball, his why,
it's two totally different why's, right?
And two totally different
ways to look at it, life.
You know, 'cause Pat's
looking back on life
and Melo's looking you know,
what he has ahead of him.
And so, it's so interesting to kind
of go with that question, the why.
- I know, it's brilliant.
I thought it was really smart.
When did you think you wanted
to start producing movies?
'Cause you got two
documentaries out right now.
One's Oscar nominated!
(audience cheering and applauding)
That's really incredible.
Yeah, so why, did you
get what I did there?
Why did you go into
producing, was this important?
- Please do all the promotion
for The Why, The Why.
- You know, I am gonna
be your street team.
I'm your street team, yeah.
- I love it.
So I feel that I've been a
storyteller my entire life.
For me to be able to accomplish things
that I have in life, I had
to tell myself the most
unbelievable story ever.
- Yeah.
- And so, there's other people out here
who are great storytellers
and have amazing stories.
And so, to have the platform that we have
to be able to uplift and
to be able to highlight
and to be able to be a
part of those stories
that you identify with,
to me, was very important,
with both of the docs that
you just talked about,
both of the shorts, "The
Dads," what's up, crew?
(audience cheering)
- Yeah!
- And "Barber of Little
Rock," these are things
that I personally identify with,
whether it's the community I grew up with
that is very similar to
"The Barber of Little Rock,"
and also being a father of Zaya Wade,
who is transgender, it dealt
with that with dads in the community.
And I was actually a little
jealous that I wasn't there,
'cause I'm like, "I need that community."
I need a community of fathers
who I can ask questions to,
I could throw things off of.
So it's just things I identify with
and I wanted to be behind 'em and support.
- So why tell the barber story?
How do you pick and choose?
Is it because it was
personal, is this one?
- Yeah, it's because it's personal.
My partner, Jon Marcus and I, we sit down
and we say, "What do we want our ethos
to be as 59th and Prairie?"
And 59th and Prairie is where I grew up.
I grew up 5901 South Prairie, Chicago,
and so, I try to think
about that community.
I try to think about that neighborhood.
I try to think about that
young kid or whatever, right?
And I try to pick stories
that kinda identifies with
what, you know, our ethos is.
And so, Arlo Washington,
shout-out to Arlo Washington,
who, he's a barber,
and if anybody know
anything about a barber
in the community-
- They hear everything,
first of all (chuckles).
- Everything, but they're the
safe haven in communities.
They're the place where
you feel the safest going,
especially when you don't
have a lot of outlets,
like the don't have in
Little Rock, Arkansas.
And so, for what he's done
in the barbershop community
by sending over 1,500 adults to school,
but also too, what he did by
starting this, People's Trust,
which is a nonprofit
bank for his community,
so people can start small businesses,
so people can have money to be able
to pay their bills, right?
And so, he is a economic warrior, he is.
He is what the community needs,
he's what our community needs.
- Investing in his
community, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's investing in his
community with his time,
with his resources, with his finances,
with his relationships.
And it's beautiful, he's a hero.
- Well, also "The Dads," the documentary,
so we have them here, actually,
the dads, there we go, yep.
- What's up, dads?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- And we have the film's
director, Luchina Fisher
in our audience as well as the dads.
So explain the documentary,
how does it play out, "Dads"?
- So the dads, they get together,
so it's a fishing trip.
And I don't know if all you guys fish,
like if everyone fish, right?
This is not something we grew up doing,
but it's a fishing trip.
And then, you know, you
start, as you watch it,
it's only like 10, 11 minutes max.
And as you start watching it,
it's just about having a community, right?
They're sitting around
the table, they're...
You know, after they fish, they go
and they cook the fish together,
they sit around a table,
they start talking about their kids,
they start talking about
their journey as well.
Your kids have a journey,
as a dad, you have a journey.
And so, just to be able to
sit and be expressive, right?
And sometimes it's hard for men, right,
just going back to the masculinity,
you don't wanna hear me be expressive
or be, what is perceived as weak.
But to be you know, around the table,
to be around that pond and be able to fish
and be expressive and be vulnerable
with what you're dealing with
as a parent in this world
and ultimately, you just wanna love,
you just want everybody else to love.
But that's not the
world we live in, right?
And so, it was great
just to see them together
and just to see that community.
Like I said, I was like,
"I want, I need that.
I need that community as well,"
because sometimes you
feel like you out here
on your own, supporting
your child, loving 'em.
- And nobody understands.
- And no one understands.
- Yeah, oh, no, I think it's important.
And also, I think we can be that world.
You know, I am a positive person,
but we can be that world,
but we need things like this.
It's just simply about loving
whoever they came out to be.
You know what I'm saying?
They came out of the
womb, whoever they are.
(audience applauding)
It's that easy.
We like to complicate
the hell outta stuff,
but it's that easy.
- It's that easy.
- Yeah, what's something
that you wanna do?
What's a dream project?
You're doing so much.
You've done so much in
your life, you're only 42.
So what's like something like a dream
that you wanna do and accomplish?
- I gotta be ready.
We were just talking about this backstage,
before I say that, I gotta
be ready for that dream.
I think the one thing about
it, we all dream for things
and we all want things,
but we may not be ready
for it when it comes.
And so, I don't know
what it looks like yet.
- I love that.
- I would love to-
- You don't wanna put the pressure
on anything.
- To work on your album
with you if you...
♪ Hey ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
If you're a producer.
- I mean, I can talk in the background.
- I like it, I like it.
- You know what I mean?
- We need another commercial break.
You can see "The Dads"
on Netflix, everybody.
Dwyane's Oscar nominated film,
"The Barber of Little
Rock" is also streaming
on the New Yorker's YouTube
channel, check that out.
And his podcast, "The
Why with Dwyane Wade,"
you've gotta check that out.
It's available wherever
you get your podcast.